[Music]
and decisions decisions means to kiss
the young lies I'm gonna buy I do the
dancing oh I do the dance oh that's
wonderful
a college football player says NC
double-a rules may force him to give up
his thriving YouTube channel
what NC double-a is it the black people
committee no after n-double-a-cp oh my
gosh it's the college National
Collegiate Athletic Association [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha ha
have you so [ __ ] random is this kid a
Division one player I don't know what's
going to play for UCF University of
Central Florida much be pretty good cuz
Central Florida [ __ ] kills what what
sport does good play football the kicker
dad I can't wait why on YouTube he
YouTube his life as a blogger
oh so he's popular uh he has about like
50k that's good yeah said so I thought
he was teaching people how to make a
ball not just three I know so he's not
teaching people how to football teaching
people like he says hey check it out
waking up about to go play a football no
I just feel like he centers a lot of his
videos around football in his life as a
college football player Oh who's just
like vlogging I mean this is actually a
pretty simple answer for you dude the
what is your life goal what is your end
goal do you want to be a youtuber
entertainer but no it's not going to
matter that's what your angle is going
to be if you want to be a [ __ ]
football player [ __ ] lock down get
rid of it and move on yeah that's what
it has to be because you know the
difference is is that YouTube will be
around for you when you're done and you
can come back if you find there not that
you don't want it but this opportunity
is not well for me I feel like why does
the end be double whatever well I'm not
questioning I'm not questioning that if
it's a rule it's already said and done
you're not going to find it so if he's
trying to make a choice on that I'm
trying to help him out right now so
that's the choice you're there's a
trajectory that people have to go on
right
you need to figure out what that end
goal is the positive thing about YouTube
is and media is always going to be there
but this opportunity won't so if you
want to be a [ __ ] football player go
at it hard court then understand it move
on we'll give you a shout-out when you
come back how about that yeah yeah so
his name is Donald Duck McDonald yeah
and so his channel has accumulated more
than 2 million views oh oh no I
congratulations yeah and so his recent
video is titled quit college sports or
quit YouTube and so what he's saying is
that the n-c-double-a is having issues
with him making videos because because
the fact things as soon as we were
saying that he cannot make money off of
his videos oh yeah that's right yeah and
um why cuz it's considering a job no
because it has to do with the sport you
can't make money off of the sport okay
they own the brand yeah well it's just
like anything so when you go to when
you're a college player or you play like
even basketball you cannot make money
off the office sport I know I have to
get sponsored either exactly oh you're
not perfect because you're not
professional yet so that's part of the
terms of being a student athlete paid
for this so the school can make all the
[ __ ] money they want on you yeah yeah
you can because it also helps with like
I guess like recruiting too so somebody
thought like you're a virgin
anybody what this untouched virgin never
been sponsored before nobody has you
know it is interesting because that's
just showing like how relevant social
media is becoming even stuff like this
because they can't even make money off
this [ __ ] which is kind of like separate
at the same time but it still has to do
with the sport interesting and he's
probably I'm assuming too that he's
going there on a scholarship then I'm
not sure usually that's what it's really
it's really strict where we're paying
for your education so you could come
play here which means you have no
financial commitments which means you
can't have a job there's only two things
to do is to do well in school or killer
sports yes in that video he was
explaining how he can't make any money
other YouTube videos and that
it really sucks because he's working
really hard on his YouTube channel he
spent hours editing his videos and
creating and doing all these things and
when there's a good thing then here's
the great thing you don't have to make
money on you can still create content
I'm being honest IB monetize it move on
you can still create that fanbase give
your fanbase what they want and then
when you come back from it or you decide
that you don't want to do it or you go
to a team you could continue it and
monetize it again but you still keep the
follow just turn on yeah don't you
coming up with all these solutions for
him it was a manager come on man how
about this part then he's saying that
his family is like you know like they
have a lot of money issues and that
there's a lot of people living in his
home and I his the bills are piling up
and his mom is calling him like crying
thing like you know they they need help
and now all that is in him and now at
this point Mikey thought he found a
solution to try to help his family by
making extra money through YouTube but
since now this whole thing happened he's
like but the point is is that when you
do something there are stipulations for
that and so those are rules that he
already knew so if his mom was banking
on him to do that there was already rule
set in play so if that was his plan to
do that when he knew this was going to
happen then that was a misstep on his
part he probably didn't know what's
going to happen yeah but you either wait
like it's already there yeah those
millions of identical cases like there's
so many star athletes that get recruited
by colleges knowing that when you leave
your home you're kind of leaving your
family wherever they are to fend for
themselves in hopes of maybe you turn
pro you know something like that so it's
not like his case is very unique it's
like when you become a student athlete
and I'm only assuming this that he is a
student athlete and he has a scholarship
and all that stuff paid for those are
all the stipulations that have already
been put in place that you made that
decision yeah and right now and the
reason why I'm saying YouTube is not the
vessel for him is because he it takes so
long for you to start making any actual
livable money off of it yeah especially
at the
subscribers that he has like how much
can you really provide right now like if
money is really the issue than the
nation
you shouldn't even consider YouTube at
this point get a job or stick with
football like that's what it sounds like
to me cuz I he really needs money you
should probably drop out of school and
go back home boy yeah I'm saying yeah
those should be the two things that he's
kind of torn between like do I take care
of my family and get a full-time job and
quit everything or do I pursue this
football thing hopefully make it big and
then have them set for life like so
should be that the real question is why
is he not acting like a normal football
jock in college and taking full
advantage of his position with the hot
teachers and cheerleaders that's a great
question
they get into I should be in on that not
[ __ ] building a YouTube channel
YouTube channels is not helping family
maybe but but also like if that was my
mom I'm like man mom you you're supposed
to be the responsible one [ __ ] paying
for [ __ ] paying for college all that why
you calling me for money dude I'm at a
time in life when I'm in college where
I'm supposed to be building myself
you're pulling me away from that [ __ ]
let me get [ __ ] my [ __ ] done if you
don't pull me off the tracks and at once
I guess somewhere then I'll take care of
you but right now you can't eat because
you [ __ ] up mom that's like it's like
when you're in an airplane and they tell
you if you're riding with a kid like you
have to put the mask on yourself first
so that you can you know take care of
your child yeah and you know also too
this is like from his his account of
what he's saying so all I don't know
anything about a situation I think just
from an outside perspective imma stick
to what I said at first if you want to
be a pro football player like that to me
is like somebody saying I want to be a
neurosurgeon you got to put that much
time and dedication into so much people
I have a friend I know we all know him
but he wanted to play pro ball and he
played pro ball internationally and he
wanted to go to the NBA he didn't make
it even when he had like laser focus to
go that way so for those people didn't
happen even and if you're debating
whether you want to keep a youtube
channel and then maybe play pro ball
which I'm not sure if that's what you
want to do then already your mind feels
kind of off because you've seen people
who want to play pro and want to be at
that
full of athleticism how much time and
dedication they put in look at copy
Brian that too before every [ __ ] game
you start shooting for three hours you
have to make an X amount of shots before
you can play the game and that's the
type of excellence that he has so at
that point if you want to play pro ball
and you want to make money and you want
to provide for your family that is a
small sacrifice they don't make you set
them up for the future looks like yeah
so good-looking dude in the video is he
looks like Devin why a little bit so no
I do not look like that I did
well what is he fighting what does he
seem that it are like his main concerns
um he feel like that n-c-double-a is
unfair I like I don't think he's really
saying that it's unfair you just saying
that
yeah he's saying that he feels that
they're making him pick between his two
passions and so not the no cuz YouTube
is a passion for him as well but they're
not cuz he could still make videos he
just can't monetize off of it so that
doesn't make any sense really are they
telling him to stop making videos are
they telling him stop making money off
the video make money off of the video
it's the money part yeah you can see me
on video so maybe he can still ask like
yo is it cool if I keep making videos
like passion project wise but I don't
take any money maybe he can say that you
know yeah 300 opportunity to learn how
to negotiate but at the same time though
if you are getting scouted or like
dishes man there's so many people that
are trying to get scouted too so it's
one of those things where like they only
pick up how many a handful of players
every year they don't pick that many so
I don't know you know it's it's kind of
like you're competing against a lot of
people if I wasn't issues I probably
just shut the channel down or I figure
out what's important to me because we
had a we had a similar [ __ ] where we
were the the our childhood show in
living color was coming back on air we
did a freaking what do you call it
we did an audition for it we got the
roles both of us they wanted both of us
but they wanted us to shut down the
channel this is back then when they saw
competition youtubers competition not
really as a platform of cross-promotion
so they they were like no like you're
going to be creating skits it's a
competing brand that's not going to work
out
we chose YouTube and I didn't get mad at
that network at all I didn't feel like
you know what you're making this choose
between two passions or whatever I just
saw it as like okay that's how you see
the world but I guess I have to think
YouTube or this I chose you to I think
the difference is is that they're not
telling him to shut down his channel he
could continue his brown Heat brand he
just cannot make money off of year and I
think that's even better for his case
because after he said this he's going to
show dedication to his fan base like
look I'm gonna still continue to make
videos I won't make money off of this
but at the same time you're still
building your brand and you still have
something to come back to when you can
enjoy your channel exactly it'll still
grow either way you just won't be
getting a paycheck from it from for now
and right now the paycheck sighs yeah
anything anyway and also like think
about Casey nice debt he did monetize
the author's videos for the longest
[ __ ] time you know and it's later on
he did but he doped that connection and
Trust with his fan base yeah I hope he
gets to keep this channel though and you
know they don't get all like now just no
videos it oh that was really funny
they'll do that because there are
football players and four players that
they do blog right now oh really yeah I
thought - yeah so the fight hope you
guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video let's wrap up
[Music]